well elon musk is a crazy brilliant
weird genius and right now probably the
most fascinating businessman in the
world this is a guy who betched the bank
on electric cars on going to space all
this stuff he's been dreaming this big
since he was a 10 year old kid he's
polarizing he can be rude and obnoxious
but i never see those as necessarily bad
qualities in the human being ultimately
he's a visionary an entrepreneur and a
guy that dreams big
i think all the things that people
criticized kierstarma for when he became
labour leader are now becoming electoral
assets they said he was too serious they
said he was a bit on the boring side
they said you know that he was a lawyer
but when you have a shambolic prime
minister somebody who's loose with the
truth and somebody who prides himself on
being able to be a buffoon then actually
as we've seen in the pandemic that can
be a catastrophic thing for a country
and so i think that kyostama and his
qualities are becoming more appealing to
the electorate rather than less
appealing
i don't understand cultural
appropriation what does it mean if
you're celebrating another culture
what's wrong with that you know i'm
irish so if people put on a green hat
and drink a pint of guinness would i be
offended no why would i if they put on
an irish accent would i be offended no
why would i i don't understand this
constant need to be offended there are
far more important things in the world
to get offended by so i think cultural
appropriation if you're mocking another
culture is unacceptable but cultural
appropriation if you're celebrating
another culture is completely acceptable
i don't think it gets plus size models
and i think of course a lot of plus size
women that want to see stuff that they
can buy in magazines and so on my
problem comes when cosmopolitan
put a
310-pound model on the cover of their
magazine with a five-page interview
inside celebrating the fact that she was
morbidly obese by morbidly obese i mean
she was i think four foot eleven or five
foot tall 310 pounds so actually she's
going to die if she's not careful
because of her excessive body weight so
rather than try and have an
inspirational piece about i've got a
real problem i need to fix it it was a
celebration of morbid obesity and that
will kill people so we've got to be
realistic about the way we tackle these
things it's not healthy to be 310 pounds
and five foot tall it's unhealthy to the
point where you're gonna die let's say
that and help people lose weight and get
fitter and yes i include myself in
that the problem with the bbc is it's
been overtaken as an institution and the
way it runs through this license fee
system by the streaming company so young
people are not going to want to pay for
the license fee as some form of enforced
tax now what they might do is do what
they do with amazon netflix and all the
other things you can get as a streaming
service is they might pay the bbc for
stuff that they want to watch but
they're not going to do it as an
obligation from the state or the
government that clock is ticking the bbc
has to present a compelling enough
amount of content people want to treat
them like a streaming service and i
think the sooner they move to that